-We're about to play
"Misname That Song."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Misname That Song ♪
♪ Misname That Song ♪
-Now I'm gonna need some help,
so joining me now
is the co-host
of the new competition series,
"Baking It," premiering
this Thursday on Peacock,
please welcome Maya Rudolph!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Misname That Song ♪
♪ Misname That Song ♪
-Oh, my.
You look fantastic.
Thank you for being here.
I appreciate it, bud.
-Hey, buddy, how are you?
-I'm great.
Let me explain
how this game works.
Okay, in front of each of us
are the incorrect names
of a number of famous songs.
Okay?
All these names are close
to the actual name of the song
but not quite right.
So when it's your turn,
you're gonna read out
the messed-up version
of that song title,
then the other person tries to
guess the correct song title
based only on that clue.
We have to guess
as many songs as possible
before the timer runs out.
Ready for this?
-You're making it sound
like it's easy.
It's hard.
-It is hard, but I don't know
what they're gonna be.
I don't plan it.
But I think you'll --
We'll be good at this.
We've done music things
together.
-Correct.
-We're good partners.
All right.
-Right.
-Since you're the guest,
you're gonna guess first.
You're gonna get 45 seconds
on the clock,
and I'm gonna give the clues.
I think we're gonna do this.
Ready?
We'll work as a team.
Here we go, bud.
-Okay.
Who's first?
-I'll start going
and see how many we can get.
-Okay, go.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Ready?
-Yep.
-Here we go.
[ Chuckles ]
Okay.
"Pelvic Bones Tell the Truth."
-"Hips Don't Lie."
-That's correct!
That's exactly
how you play the game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Not Particularly Taxing
on Myself."
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-It's a really new song.
♪ Taxing ♪
I'm gonna pass.
I'm going to pass that one.
Passing.
Go.
"I Would Like
to Experience Rhythmic Movement
with Another Human."
-"I Wanna Dance With Somebody"!
-That's correct!
Oh, you know how to do this.
"Liquid Atop
Movie Theater Popcorn."
-Water --
-No. Water?
[ Wah wah! ]
Close.
"Butter."
-You said liquid.
-"Butter."
Liquid atop
movie-theater popcorn.
Butter?
-Oh, I thought you meant
a top movie-theater chain.
I said the Regal.
[ Laughter ]
-Regal.
It is a top movie-theater chain.
-It's the most
premier movie chain
in all of the United States.
-Last time we were on the show,
we always play "What is the most
premier movie chains?"
-And I can't
stop talking about the Regal.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, Maya.
We got two there.
-I got Regal socks.
I told you
I'm great at this game.
-No, this is good.
Because two is great.
Two is -- And, again, we're
partners, so this is beatable.
So now it's my turn.
We'll put another 45 seconds
on the clock.
And whenever you're ready,
read the misnamed song title,
and I will guess.
-Okay.
Are you ready?
-Yes.
-"Pleasant Shakiness."
-Nice -- nice --
Pleasant...
-Fun?
-...Shakiness.
-"Hippy Shake"?
[ Laughter ]
"Rattle"?
"Shake, Rattle, Roll"?
Pass.
-Shakiness or another kind of --
Do you want me to pass?
-Yeah, pass.
-Okay.
"Tequila-Forward Cocktail Town."
[ Laughter ]
You got this.
-Oh, "Margaritaville."
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"I Appreciate
the Popular Style of Music
Driven by
Loud Guitar and Vocals."
-"I Love Rock 'n' Roll."
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Female Jelly."
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-What?
-I just wanted to talk
to you today about female jelly,
that's all.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
Let's talk about
different movie-theater chains.
-It was "Lady Marmalade."
-Ah!
Yeah, "Lady Marmalade."
Okay, all right, look.
We're tied.
That means we're in the zone.
-That means we're going
for the death sequence.
-This is the death sequence,
what they call --
We changed the name
to call it the fun round.
[ Laughter ]
For this last round,
we're gonna see how many songs
we can name together.
We're gonna take turns naming
a song and then guessing.
I will start us off
by reading the first clue.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
"Ponder Barrier."
[ Laughter ]
-"Think Wall"?
-Something --
-"Wonderwall."
-Yes, that's right! Correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"You Are the Only Thing
on my Holiday Wish List."
-"All I Want for Christmas
Is You."
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-"Slap Bass Above 59th Street."
-Slap -- Funk.
Funk?
-What kind of funk?
Where's above 59th street?
-"Uptown Funk"!
-That's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"I Prefer It
in that Particular Manner."
-♪ "I Want It That Way" ♪
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is Maya Rudolph
right there.
We make a pretty good team.